so did you know that where you live
determines on how much money you make on
YouTube what are the most profitable
topics on YouTube why is my ad Revenue
going down the content in your videos
can drive your CPM down
so how does YouTube monetization
actually work why do some creators make
more money than you in this video we're
actually going to be defining some key
terms we're going to be talking about
what is CPM what is rpm and some new
updates to how YouTube pays creators and
we're also going to be talking about the
seven things that influence how much
money you earn on YouTube plus the seven
most profitable Channel topics According
to some research and really this is
going to be a deep dive training so
buckle your seat belt and I'm going to
be revealing how much money we have made
at think media over the past 90 days and
some of the insights we've learned from
the different types of content that are
paying the most and so let's first
Define how YouTube pays creators once
you get approved for the YouTube Partner
program after getting 1 000 subscribers
4 000 hours of watch time in a rolling
12-month period period or if you get 10
million shorts views in 90 days you can
qualify plus having a thousand
subscribers then you qualify to apply
for the YouTube Partner program once in
you can start earning money and the
first calculation of how you earn money
on YouTube is CPM stands for cost per
Milli and it's really cost per a
thousand Impressions Millie is a
thousand I believe in like Roman days or
something like that and so it's the cost
The Advertiser needs to pay on YouTube
for every a thousand Impressions their
ad receives on on a video now an
impression doesn't mean they've clicked
through on the video it just means that
the ad was actually seen there's an
additional type of CPM though called
playback based CPM so rather than
calculating the cost an Advertiser pays
for a thousand Impressions playback CPM
calculates the cost and Advertiser pays
for 1 000 video playbooks uh backs where
the ad is displayed so the let's
simplify what is CPM CPM is basically
the amount of money an Advertiser is
willing to pay to advertise on your
videos and this varies by industry and
we're going to clarify some of the
highest paying Industries all the
different details
and to be clear this is the total amount
of money that YouTube collects from a
business or a brand that pays to
advertise with them before there's any
kind of split and so it's being measured
by a thousand Impressions and thousand
video views and it's also I think
important to know that just because
let's say you get a thousand views it
doesn't mean an ad actually play
sometimes people use Adblock blocker
YouTube doesn't always Force ads to play
even if you check every box of
monetization it doesn't mean an ad will
play so without getting too much into
the weeds it's just if you're ever like
well I got you know 100 000 views
shouldn't those all count towards
monetization well if it's playback based
it means that actually The Advertiser is
playing when their ad is actually
displayed so then there's a second term
like what's the difference between CPM
and RPM well if CPM is how much money
YouTube gets total so let's say a brand
is like I'm gonna give you a hundred
dollars RPM is how much money you the
Creator get so YouTube typically they
say is going to take
55 percent
or rather actually we'll hit these
numbers later and we'll actually maybe
reveal why this isn't true but what
YouTube says is that YouTube will pay 55
of net revenues to creators so they take
45 you get 55 we're going to dispel some
myths later because I actually don't
think that that is true
um but uh you let me know if you're
watching the video version of this
podcast in the YouTube comments what
your experience has been in terms of
like how much money you earn but let's
break it down CPM is the let's say
YouTube the the YouTube collects a
hundred dollars from a business well
then they would pay the Creator let's
say 45 of of that transaction or it
could be 30 or 50 or 60. but your RPM is
how much represents the amount of money
you've earned per thousand views so RPM
is kind of the more important number in
a way both actually are worth measuring
but RPM when it really comes to to being
able to pay your bills pay your mortgage
you're going to need the money you
actually collect not just the money that
YouTube collects you're going to need
YouTube to get some money from a
business and then they're going to give
you your cut and your cut is what you
can actually deposit in the bank problem
with RPM though is that RPM is actually
based on several Revenue sources and I
don't know if YouTube did this to mess
with us but
it can be kind of confusing because it
is YouTube ads that would be the
clearest but it's also Channel
memberships it's also YouTube premium
Revenue it's also super chats and it's
also super stickers now it's kind of
nice to think media is these are not
really income streams we lean on we
don't do Channel memberships we do earn
YouTube premium revenue and that so
would it everybody who's monetized it
just means viewers that have YouTube
premium ads are not being served to them
you pay for YouTube premium to avoid ads
I'm a YouTube premium user so when I
watch YouTube videos every video I watch
if it's monetized gets a cut of the pool
of YouTube premium Revenue I know are we
geeky yet buckle your seat belt because
we're really getting into the weeds here
but this is a deep dive training and so
the problem with RPM is you could be
like oh cool my RPM is really high well
if you're getting super chats you're
getting Channel memberships in my
opinion it kind of dilutes the number
like I want to know what I'm just
getting in the ads relationship and I
would love to just separate out these
other streams of Revenue so here's a
question how much are creators actually
earning and Business Insider did an
article this will be a range and we're
going to talk about why this could be
higher and lower I know we have an
international audience different
countries different demos they earn
different amounts of money but here's
what Business Insider revealed and these
were RPM metrics creators said they got
paid between
1.61 cents and 29.30 for 1 000 views on
their long form videos
that's a big range and that's the RPM
that's how much they actually earned so
depending on the niche for the topic 29
is an insanely high RPM and 161 is not
even necessarily terrible but is
obviously on the lower end and depending
on the niche or the quality of the
content it could be even lower let's try
to simplify some things bottom line if
you ultimately were earning two dollars
per a thousand views and you got a
million views and they were all
monetized you would earn two thousand
dollars if you had a two dollar CPM you
would actually YouTube would take like
half of that and you'd get the other
half of it so you get it like RPM is how
much you keep CPM is the total amount
that you share with YouTube so if you
had a thirty dollar RPM and you got a
million views you would make thirty
thousand dollars so these things really
matter obviously in terms of how much is
possible to earn and the questions are
how do we increase this and what are the
best types of content now in this
Business Insider article they also
discovered that shorts make a lot less
money and the average there was creators
were earning between four cents to six
cents RPM for a thousand views and we've
experienced that at think media we
earned six cents for a thousand views at
think media that's our RPM on our shorts
but our
RPM on our long form videos is much
higher and so in just a second we're
going to get into the seven uh ways that
uh seven things that affect CPM RPM how
to raise it we're going to get into the
most profitable niches but let me reveal
some numbers that only I know and these
are just think media numbers at the time
of recording the think media podcast
episode that we're doing this is January
2023 through almost the end of April not
quite the end of April there's five or
six days left okay
so when I set a date range inside of my
YouTube analytics it'll fluctuate these
numbers this is a way to measure it so I
actually was able to go back and look at
what January February and March and the
RPM changed every month but this is then
when you use your YouTube analytics you
set a date range I set a date range for
roughly three months on our think media
channel in 2023. our videos had an RPM
of 7.98
so for every 1000 views
that's how much we get to keep on our
videos and fan funding during that
entire time was only like a hundred and
fifty dollars because remember if we had
like a lot of live streaming and super
chats with something we really focused
on
um or there was even Channel memberships
so that those numbers are not really
mixed with any any other income streams
that's all just the amount of money
we're earning from ads on our videos our
shorts during the last 90 days earned
six cents and our live streams had an
RPM of
15.27 now disclaimer I don't think
that's because I don't think the lesson
there is that live streaming inherently
pays more my prediction is from what
we've seen at think media that when I go
live with like deep dive trainings that
are also that very educational and
they're about YouTube making money
online uh very tactical and I think they
attract an audience that's probably
similar to you
someone that's smart you know wants to
learn uh serious you're not just looking
for fluff entertainment if you're
listening to this deep dive about CPM
versus RPM
so apply the insights to your Channel or
test it how you will but that's pretty
legit so when I go live and then the
replay values of my live streams are
good and they're long that's maybe
helpful as well because they could be
closer to an hour there's multiple ad
spots but even that being said it
wouldn't necessarily mean the RPM is
higher it just mean that more ads are
served so that's it around eight dollars
per
um for videos around six cents for
shorts and 15 for live streams was think
media over the last 90 days now watch
this CPM over the last 90 days was 20.49
so as I'm able to look I'm looking at
think media the reason I like CPM in
terms of studying things is just to
understand hey what's the channel worth
it's not what what our cut is but it's
like what is our content worth what is
the value of our content what are
advertisers willing to pay to advertise
on our content and it doesn't
necessarily mean advertisers are picking
out to advertise on think media although
they could be they're they're looking
for a particular demographic Maybe
particular keywords
um they're they're that's a it's a
bidding Marketplace that advertisers pay
to get in front of certain audiences and
so because it's a a bidding Marketplace
things get bit up supply and demand
competition so think media in the last
90 days was worth 20.49 but now let's
kind of do the rough math if we only
earn eight dollars RPM then we earn 39
and YouTube earned 61 percent
now I've been in the YouTube game for a
while
as far as I'm concerned to me that
doesn't seem to be that YouTube will pay
me 55 of net revenues
apparently I'm getting paid 39 of net
revenues now if you're watching this or
especially if you if you're listening to
this
um it's you can't really comment on the
audio platforms but if you're watching
this leave me a comment because maybe
there's something I don't know if you're
from YouTube I'd love to understand this
more but and by the way I'm not I I
ain't even mad about it but we earned 39
according to my horrible math probably
and YouTube Took 61 percent so when they
say this and they say this on the Google
page that when you turn on ads YouTube
will pay you 55 of net revenues for ads
displayed or streamed on public videos
on your videos so that's long form
content not shorts okay or just normal
videos not shorts so there you go and
and that's how I come to that conclude I
look at what our CPM is I look at what
our RPM is and if you're like well I'm
making like 80 well is your RPM mixed
with Super Chat super stickers YouTube
premium Revenue that's something to
consider and ours really isn't and so
let's go a little bit deeper but before
we get into some of these tactics and
tips but here's also in the last 90 days
where our money came from I'm going to
give you the total this actually might
have been four months January February
March April that's actually four months
to be clear like five or six days short
of four months for all of these numbers
okay fan funding we earned 150 dollars
not a lot of super chats or anything
that's all it would have been maybe
people doing the thank yous and we never
ask for them and we really don't go live
that much okay shorts feed ads so this
would be the proper ads playing in the
shorts feed over four months on our
content
1197 YouTube premium four thousand two
hundred and eighty dollars watch page
ads your standard in-stream ads on
normal videos 151 098 dollars
so in think media's case our normal
videos with our close to eight dollar
RPM that's where the game is in terms of
making real money from YouTube ad
Revenue the total for almost four months
and 20 to 23 for think media was 156
727.21 not too bad so
um and as you can imagine
you know it's a good money but think
media is also not a solo YouTube Creator
anymore we have multiple creators
editors helping now graphic design so it
is also kind of important for a channel
like ours that's if you could imagine
the same kind of content or the same
kind of numbers or the same kind of
reach uh I don't actually have the
amount of views that we got in that time
forgive me because that would be
interesting as well but at least gives
you kind of an idea CPM RPM and so um
let's talk about then ultimately what
influences how you could raise your CPM
remember that's not how much you get to
keep but nevertheless let's make that
Top Line number as high as possible and
you can't affect the percentages in the
middle right the RPM like how much
YouTube's going to give you a cut I
don't I can't think of one activity I
could do but if I can get a higher CPM
meaning what advertisers are willing to
pay then YouTube is going to distribute
whatever they want to me and the caveat
for this whole thing is why I 100
recommend you monetize in other ways
other than ad Revenue like if you
haven't watched our free class at
thinkmasterclass.com
you definitely want to diversify your
income that's actually why I'm not mad
about it creators probably are a lot
more angry about some of these things
like wait a minute I didn't get 55 why
is this going up why is this going down
you got to take your destiny into your
own hands you cannot put the keys to
your kingdom in the hands of YouTube
ultimately nothing but love and
gratitude for this free platform for the
opportunity to reach people for all of
the cool technology upload 1080 4K
content 8K content you know Reach people
YouTube's amazing and I don't think we
should ever we should feel grateful not
entitled
but I think where a lot of anxiety comes
is if you only rely on YouTube ad
Revenue it's going to be hard to sleep
at night even if you're really
successful because it can be hot it can
go up and down but nevertheless 156 727
is a big piece of
um maybe not even a big piece
uh it is a significant piece of our
think media ecosystem
so how can we grow our CPM and how can
you increase the CPM on your YouTube
channel number one the geographic
location listed on your channel so did
you know that where you live determines
on how much money you make on YouTube
some countries have larger economies
than others and that abundance
translates to YouTube now actually by
the way vidiq did a cool article and
that's where I pulled these seven things
and combined it with some of my other
research I will admit that you might
feel limited by okay well my country
pays a lower amount of money but my
Studies have revealed that it's actually
where your audience is a little bit more
than where your actual channel is listed
like for example what if I started going
nomadic and I started traveling the
world and I'm uploading in Thailand and
Vietnam and Australia and I'm just
traveling but think media is based in
the United States maybe it's where your
channel is started but the big key is
where are your viewers and what is the
economic spending of your viewers in
fact what who
advertisers want to reach but number one
is geographic location of your channel
number two is the age of your audience
advertisers want to be where money flows
so what is their age think about this in
terms of their buying power and then
their buying Behavior not only how much
buying power do they have how much
disposable income do they have and what
is their buying Behavior this is why you
might say well I wish rich people watch
my content on YouTube
are you creating content that attracts
affluent people this is why getting
clear on your target audience and
reverse engineering the kind of content
you create is key and advertising
ultimately is about getting the right
message in front of the right people
that take put on the shoes and put on
the spectacles of The Advertiser the
brand or business that wants to reach a
target audience would they want to
advertise on your channel and besides
your channel topic in terms of the
quality of your content or who you're
talking to or who's watching whose
attention can you hold who's respect can
you hold it's the challenge of like you
as a 20 year old life coach you may not
actually be influencing a lot of 40 and
50 year olds they just might not trust
you to coach them on life which is fine
it would be just being aware of okay the
content I'm creating who's it actually
influencing now if you were a 20 year
old curator of financial experts like
Warren Buffett and Charlie Munger and
you you are doing a faceless channel the
audience consuming that content might be
people in their 35 and above 45 55 that
want to learn tips on investing and
therefore you're getting paid more
because you're talking about personal
finance because advertisers want to get
in front of people that are watching
that content so there's different ways
to look at okay who's watching my
content what's the geographic location
what is the age of my audience three
what is your YouTube Niche or industry
so what are the most profitable topics
on YouTube now there are many and
there's a lot of opportunity but there
was some research done by a creator that
discovered seven niches that make the
most money and here they are Health
business investing auto reviews real
estate insurance and online marketing
and this data was collected by studying
cpms and different niches across Russia
the US Canada the UK Germany Australia
and India so global
deep dive study what are the highest
cpms health business investing auto
reviews real estate insurance and online
marketing so what are the most
profitable topics on YouTube now if you
were trying to financially position your
channel to have the greatest Advantage
it would be smart to pick a high-paying
industry not just for CPM perhaps but
because of brand deal sponsorships and
other opportunities it doesn't mean
however though that you'd have to be in
one of those seven I think you
understand that but it could also speak
to the financial upside or lack of
upside at least in terms of how much
you're going to make from ad Revenue so
one of the questions that you should be
thinking is how much is how much are
businesses willing to pay to advertise
to this demographic if you think about
it if it's auto reviews someone's
actually going to buy a car and if it
was a loan product of some kind perhaps
or if it was Insurance of of something
like that like these that would be a
lucrative audience to advertise in front
of it might be harder to sell Auto
Insurance on a mine craft playthrough
video so again that's the thinking we
want to develop and so think about this
what products are being sold to this
audience if you're selling Medical
Services to Baby Boomers they need a lot
more Medical Services
medical and Health Services are
incredibly expensive think about cancer
treatments
so sometimes the cpms of of the health
industry can be 50 60 80 100 plus people
that are doing Investments or getting
loans to Gen X so now we're combining
just age and Industry what about SAS
solutions for business owners SAS stands
for software as a service what about
luxury cars what kind of content has an
audience that would purchase luxury cars
and then what about fast fashion and
drugstore makeup what kind of content
maybe does have a high margin business
still but it's more like even if it's
more affordable products fashion makeup
what about app downloads to Gamers with
in-app purchases maybe that's not as
much of a high CPM but it's a massive
reach so typically if you go into
something like luxury you have smaller
amount of buyers a smaller audience but
a higher value and then on the flip side
if you go into something like gaming or
mobile gaming you have millions and
millions and tens of millions of
customers potentially but maybe the
amount you're earning the CPM per view
and even the economics of the app itself
it's a one-to-many play it's a digital
good it's in-app purchases so they're
willing a brand is willing to their cost
of acquiring a customer is a lot lower
than somebody that is the cost of
acquiring a customer for a retirement
home or for a cancer treatment number
four seasonal changes in your Niche or
your industry
if you're ever wondering why is my CPM
going higher or going lower if you're
ever concerned about man why are why is
my ad Revenue going down on YouTube one
of the things to know is that it does
fluctuate through Seasons which is out
of your control in fact there's many
external factors some certain Seasons it
just goes down there's also times when
advertisers spend more they spend less
there's times when the US government was
printing insane amounts of money and the
whole stock market and businesses and
everything was just getting absolutely
inflated and so everything inflates
during a season like that unless you are
Jerome Powell and you work at the fed
you can't really influence that so so
there's certain seasonal things and then
certain niches go up or down so perhaps
in January you have a fitness channel
or health and it's related to somebody
thinking New Year New You and lots of
people want to get in front of them at
the end of December and the end of
January with Health Products because
people are thinking diet they're
thinking lose weight they're thinking
get fit they're thinking productivity
they're thinking goal setting and so you
your content might go through the roof
during that time
um and then there's maybe other times
where by February March people are like
I gave up on my diet I gave up on my
goals I gave up on my productivity I
gave up on my fitness
um and so cpms are going down and it's
out of your control I have a tech
channel right think media talks about
cameras tech and during Christmas or
even pre that you go Black Friday Cyber
Monday our ad Revenue usually uh not
only usually always is high towards the
end of the year as it's that season
where a lot of people have sales holiday
sales
so that's number four number five the
types of ads placed on your videos when
you get monetized and you upload a video
you can say turn on ads and then you can
go into monetization and you can check
boxes of the type of ads you want played
on your videos
we typically and sometimes by default I
think just all the boxes are checked but
a key here is you could for example say
I never want non-skippable ads played on
my videos have you ever watched those
like you have to watch the full 15
second ad or the full 30 second ad I
never want that
um I only want skippable what I've
learned is I just check them all because
what I've also learned is they just
don't always play like YouTube is
curating the viewers experience they
want to push ads to make money because
that is how YouTube owned by alphabet
the parent company of YouTube and Google
that's how they make money but they also
don't want to spam people so many ads
that they lose Goodwill and it's
probably attention that's constantly
being managed that's just why
non-skippable ads are not always playing
or it's up to YouTube basically so I
just check all the boxes but here's a
key
um I went into the last about four
months of think media and close to 80 of
our ads were skippable video ads and six
percent were non-skippable and six
percent were display ads and four
percent were bumper ads and four percent
were non-skippable ads and so the way
you see this is you go to analytics
Revenue watch page ads which is how
different ads make money and if you say
Sean why does this matter or what should
I do to influence this I would say
probably nothing I would I personally
would just check all the boxes and let
YouTube do its thing and focus on making
your next best video but the key is that
different ads pay different amounts
number six made for kids content
if you check the box that this content
was made for kids and if the content was
made for kids you should check the box a
couple years ago YouTube was fined 170
million dollars for violating the
children's online Privacy Act this law
states that websites can't collect
personal information from users under 13
years of age so that means that if you
have a kids channel it essentially means
that you're going to make Less ad
Revenue so YouTube isn't allowed to
collect personal data from most children
or from children and as a result those
views are not going to be as targeted as
other views what does that mean it means
that users that are over 13 you've
probably seen this all the websites
you're going to all your activity on
Google all the other watch history of
videos you're watching everything you're
doing even other data about you through
all kinds of different tactics Google
knows a lot meta knows a lot about maybe
how much money you make roughly or what
your habits are the know a lot about you
right and it's a whole privacy
conversation but what the law states the
children's online Privacy Act is that
businesses are not allowed to collect
that information about people under 13.
okay so if that's true all these
advertisers are willing to pay a hundred
dollar cpms to reach Baby Boomers
because that are maybe even of a certain
economic level to get a certain medical
solution in front of them cool kids they
go okay we know these are children but
that's all we know like we know they're
under 13 so it just does not command as
high of cpms so the bottom line is just
like you if your content is for people
under 13 you should check the box that
this content is made for kids but if you
have a kids channel that is a factor
that could be driving your you YouTube
CPM way down and don't sweat it I know
that could be stressful I wish the world
was different wishing things were
different than they are has turned out
to never really be much of an effective
strategy I think you just kind of
embrace the reality or should I not do a
kid's Channel well that's up to you but
if you can put out great kids content
you could get millions and millions of
views you could still make good money if
you put out great kids content I I hope
blippi is checking the box for made for
kids because I think it is and obviously
it's a pretty crazy case study but
blippi's got he's got the fake blackby
you know that guy have you seen him like
it's not the real blippi I happen to be
a blippi expert now that I have a two
and a half year old you've got his
blippi's YouTube channel not only blew
up he hustled he started building it but
then you've got action figures you've
got Biz Dev you've got Netflix shows now
you have blippi and Mika you have all of
this he scaled an Empire well you can
build your Empire as well so remember
that CPM is not everything and ads are
not everything building a brand becoming
known at the end of his episode he goes
let's spell it out together if you're
ever looking for more blippi let's do it
b l i p p i like my son doesn't even
know how to spell or letters or words
and he knows how to spell blippi and
find him on my Smart TV like branding
right and so
even if your CPM is driven down because
of kids content
it's okay
we're gonna be okay
you can adapt and create
the ideal strategy for your YouTube
business model your target audience
however these seven things could be very
helpful for us right for making informed
decisions about our content
in the future number seven how safe are
your videos for viewing the content in
your videos can drive your CPM down so
there's an article that Google has out
of what content is not suitable for ads
or will result in limited or no ads
when it comes to monetization so there's
two things that could happen if you have
questionable content in your videos
number one ads are just disallowed
completely or number two they're limited
or no ads which typically tanks your you
might make it instead of making 10 or 20
grand a video for big creators they'll
make two grand significantly throttled
amount of money so here are some of the
main topics that are not Advertiser
friendly and this is not even an
exhaustive list but it's quite a bit of
things
so these things can drive down how much
money you earn from YouTube
inappropriate language violence adult
content shocking content harmful or
dangerous acts hateful or derogatory
content recreational drugs and drug
related content Firearms related content
controversial issues sensitive events
incendiary or demeaning content
tobacco-related content and adult themes
in family content so the summary there
is PG PG-13 family friendly content is
going to have the greatest opportunity
for the most ads this is a whole
conversation in and of itself because
some creators who have more adult themed
content want they say well there's a lot
of brands or businesses that would want
to reach our audience but my rebuttal to
that would be yeah and that's why you
can do brand deals and that's why you
can do your own thing and you can build
your own platforms other places or you
could have you build an email list and
you can sell email drops to sponsors but
I empathize I mean I see the frustration
is sometimes people sometimes these
things are unclear or sometimes you
don't know why your video has limited or
no ads but nevertheless if you want the
safest bet of not having limited ads on
your YouTube videos than being
thoughtful of those types of keeping
inappropriate language and violence and
harmful content out of your videos would
be an important factor for just avoiding
any of that drama in any of that trauma
so ultimately what questions do you
still have about monetization let me
know especially if you watch this on
YouTube where you're able to comment if
you are part of our audio Community then
it would mean the world to me if you
reviewed the podcast on Spotify or
you'll have to review and rated this on
Apple seriously if you got value out of
this episode that would go a long way
for all the research that went into it
and we covered right these seven
different distinctions of CPM and seven
most profitable Channel topics in there
and also how much we made at think media
so we covered a lot so save this one for
reference and even share this with maybe
somebody else that would benefit from
some of this information and I am Sean
Cannell rhymes with YouTube channel this
has been the think media podcast and I
look forward to connecting with you in a
future episode